thought that was i had no idea is this
the is it is this live tv
unbelievable lisa kudrow you live
in you live there too
yeah where else would i live yeah let's
call this the one
where the friends cast has a mini
reunion at the 2020 emmys
yeah where else would i live i don't
know with your family maybe
yeah like people live with their
families
let's rewind things kicked off at the
top of the night when jennifer aniston
appeared in person at the staples center
to present an award
but jen an emmy nominee herself quickly
bolted out of the building after host
jimmy kimmel told her trophies were
being delivered to the nominees at home
this year
you better get home then there's only
nine hours before your category thanks
jimmy
what oh god later in the show jimmy
checked on his pal
jen to make sure she made it home in
time for her category
i barely made it but uh we're here oh
hey okay hey jimmy look at this courtney
cox courtney's there
of course i'm here we live together you
do
uh yeah we've been roommates since 1994
jimmy
and naturally lisa kudrow was there too
i thought that was i had no idea is this
the
is it is this live tv unbelievable
lisa kudrow you live in you live there
too
yeah where else would i live
the moment obviously got friends fans
everywhere even more hyped for the
highly anticipated one-time reunion
special
which was set to air on hbo max in may
but got delayed due to the coronavirus
pandemic
we're gonna all get together for the
first time
in a room and actually talk about the
show friends co-creator marta kaufman
told et in august
that the cast is waiting to resume
filming till they can do so in front of
a live studio audience
there was a real resurgence of the show
because of the 25th anniversary of the
show
uh there was a lot of love
a lot of love sent out for it and i
think um the cast is incredibly grateful
and want to give back you know by doing
this special